INTRO:
Nowadays, WhatsApp has become a meme on YouTube
due to all of the bitcoin and crypto scammers
in the comment section that tell you to contact
them through WhatsApp.
Given this poor association and the relative
unpopularity of WhatsApp within the US, a
lot of Americans likely write off the app
as just a gateway for scammers.
But, outside the US, WhatsApp is a lot more
than just that.
In fact, in many developing countries and
Europe, WhatsApp is often the primary form
of communication.
Instead of using traditional SMS and calls,
WhatsApp uses the internet to facilitate these
communications which is extremely convenient
and cheap, especially for international communication.
In other words, WhatsApp is basically the
iMessage and Facetime of non-Americans.
Considering this, I don’t think you’d
be surprised to hear that WhatsApp is the
world’s most popular messaging app with
a total of 2 billion active monthly users.
Despite WhatsApp’s explosive success, both
of WhatsApp’s founders left the company
in 2018 citing privacy and monetization concerns.
So, here’s what happened to the founders
of the most popular messaging app in the world.
JAN KOUM:
Taking a look back, the story of WhatsApp
circles back to two men named Jan Koum and
Brian Acton.
Jan was born on February 24, 1976, in Kyiv,
Ukraine to a Jewish family.
Jan was an only child, so his parents gave
him extra love and attention, but no amount
of care was able to cover up the reality of
their living situation.
Jan’s house didn’t even have running water,
and it wasn’t much better at school.
Jan says that his school didn’t have a bathroom
inside the building.
So kids had to run across the parking lot
to just use the bathroom which was especially
painful when the temperature was -20 degrees
Celsius.
Aside from poor living conditions, Jan says
that the social life wasn’t that much better
due to all the discrimination against Jews.
Jan’s family had put up with this for decades,
but when Jan turned 16, they decided to immigrate
to Mountain View, California.
This move eliminated a lot of the outright
discrimination they experienced and the lack
of opportunities that accompanied socialism.
But, life in the US was still quite difficult
because they had no money and had trouble
communicating.
To make ends meet, Jan’s mother had to start
babysitting and Jan had to become a cleaner
at a grocery store.
The family also had to use welfare checks
and food stamps.
In terms of school, Jan admits that he wasn’t
the best of students and that he barely got
through high school, but this didn’t mean
that he hated learning.
He enjoyed reading books about computer science
and teaching himself coding.
Apparently, he would buy coding books from
a local book store, read them really fast,
and then return them to save money.
Anyway, moving onto college, Jan would attend
San Jose State University and he would pick
up a side job as a security tester at Ernst
and Young to pay for his education.
But, this job would end up being a lot more
valuable than just helping pay for college.
You see, Jan would meet an early Yahoo employee
named Brain Acton while completing a project
for Ernst & Young.
6 months later, Brian would help Jan get a
job at Yahoo, and that marked the beginning
of the partnership that would eventually turn
into WhatsApp.
BRIAN ACTON:
Taking a look back at Brian’s past, it’s
a lot different than Jan’s past.
Brian was born on February 17, 1972, in Michigan.
His mother ran a freight shipping business,
and she was the one that really inspired Brian
to pursue entrepreneurship.
Ironically, Jan actually hates this word and
doesn’t like it when people call him an
entrepreneur.
He feels that the main goal of traditional
entrepreneurs is to make money while his main
goal is to make useful products.
Anyway, going back to Brian, it looks like
he was a star student at school.
He would attend Lake Howell High School in
central Florida and would earn a full scholarship
to study engineering at the University of
Pennsylvania.
He only stuck around at UPenn for a year though
before he switched over to Stanford to get
a computer science degree.
With such a rich educational background, it
was easy for Brian to enter the workforce
and switch from one job to another until he
found his calling.
In 1992, he started off as a systems administrator
at Rockwell International.
After that, he became a product tester at
Apple before becoming a product tester at
Adobe.
While Brian didn’t know exactly what he
wanted to do in the early days, he soon found
himself looking back at his childhood and
his mother and decided that he wanted to give
entrepreneurship a shot.
So, in 1996, he joined Yahoo as their 44th
employee and this is when he would meet Jan
Koum.
For the next decade, Brian and Jan would stick
around at Yahoo, and just consistently save
up their money.
While their professional lives were progressing
pretty smoothly, the same could not be said
about their personal lives.
In February of 1996, Jan would verbally and
physically threaten an ex-girlfriend after
they broke up, and the girlfriend would end
up filing a restraining order against him.
Jan has since expressed that he’s extremely
embarrassed and ashamed of his behavior.
In the meantime, Brian was having a great
time in the late 1990s.
He was investing heavily in dot-com companies
which made him a multi-millionaire.
But, once the dot-com bubble burst, he would
lose most of it.
While I’m sure he was fine financially thanks
to his job and savings, this was likely an
extremely painful event.
Nonetheless, the duo got through these events
and would eventually leave Yahoo in 2007.
Soon after, they both tried to get jobs at
Facebook, but both of them would be rejected.
I don’t think Jan nor Brian really cared
that much though.
With over a decade of experience within the
tech field, they had already made plenty of
money.
So, they decided to take it easy and go on
a one-year vacation to South America and play
ultimate frisbee.
When they came back, Jan would buy an iPhone
in January of 2009, and this was the beginning
of WhatsApp.
FOUNDING WHATSAPP:
As soon as Jan got an iPhone, he knew that
the App store was going to be huge.
So, he started talking with Brian and another
friend named Alex Fishman about potential
apps that they could launch.
One month later, on Jan’s 33rd birthday,
he would incorporate the company WhatsApp.
The name is of course a reference to the popular
saying What’s Up.
Despite incorporating the company, Jan didn’t
really know what they wanted to create.
He knew they wanted to do something relating
to social media, hence the name, but initially,
he was actually leaning towards status updates.
It wasn’t until August of 2009 that he incorporated
a messaging aspect into the app, and this
is what really accelerated the adoption of
the app.
At this point, Jan did most of the work and
owned the entirety of the company.
In the meantime, Brian was still unemployed
and looking for potential employment.
So, Jan offered to make Brian a cofounder
if he could raise the company some money.
Fortunately for Brian, this was rather easy.
He hit up a couple of his friends from Yahoo
and was able to raise a total of $250,000
for WhatsApp.
And with that, Brian and Jan were able to
go all-in on WhatsApp.
From the very beginning, one of the duo’s
top priorities was privacy.
Jan says quote, “We want to know as little
about our users as possible...
We're not advertisement-driven so we don't
need personal databases."
You could say these were some famous last
words.
Anyway, WhatsApp quickly started to gain popularity,
especially within developing countries where
WhatsApp was the best internet-based mobile
messaging service available.
Hundreds of thousands of users turned into
millions of users and millions of users turned
into tens of millions of users.
Despite the popularity of the app, the duo
didn’t really have a smart way to monetize
the app.
So, they were burning money left right trying
to keep operations afloat.
Fortunately, in 2011, they would successfully
raise $8 million from Sequoia Capital, but
both of them knew that with how fast WhatsApp
was growing, it was just a matter of time
until this money would run out.
Thankfully, Mark would reach out just in time.
HITTING IT BIG:
WhatsApp caught the attention of Mark Zuckerberg
very early on, and Mark would quickly start
building up a relationship with Jan and Brian.
In 2012, Mark called Jan and the two would
get some coffee and go on a hike.
Over the next two years, the two would stay
in contact, and eventually, in February of
2014, Mark would invite Jan over for dinner,
and during dinner, Mark made Jan an offer
he couldn’t refuse.
He offered to buy the money-losing company
with little revenue for a whopping $19 billion.
WhatsApp was definitely not worth anywhere
near $19 billion at the time, but Mark could
see the long-term potential of the company.
Meanwhile, Jan likely knew that WhatsApp could
eventually grow well past $19 billion naturally.
But, that would be a long and tough journey
filled with risk, so, taking the buyout was
a no-brainer.
Soon after, Jan would sign the acquisition
papers on the door of his old welfare office,
and with that Jan and Brian were officially
billionaires.
With the backing of Facebook, Jan and Brian
were able to test and implement new features
faster than ever before.
One of the first features they implemented
after the acquisition was voice calls.
And by June of 2016, more than 100 million
voice calls were being placed on WhatsApp
on a daily basis.
Soon after they launched video calls, two-step
verification, and WhatsApp Business.
Aside from introducing new features, WhatsApp
could relax their monetization effort thanks
to Facebook.
So, in January of 2016, they would remove
their annual $1 fee which made WhatsApp more
accessible than ever before.
Despite all these advantages, there were also
a few notable disadvantages namely a reduction
in user privacy.
During the summer of 2016, WhatsApp would
begin sharing user info with Facebook for
targeted ads.
Neither Brian nor Jan were big fans of this
decision, and they would both leave Facebook
soon after, but not before securing their
full stock compensations.
SIGNAL:
Brian would be the first to leave Facebook
in September of 2017, and Jan would leave
Facebook 7 months later in April of 2018.
Ironically, both of them would start trashing
Facebook as soon as they left.
Jan has expressed his grievances about Facebook
to the media on several occasions.
Meanwhile, Brian straight up advocates for
people to delete Facebook.
Clearly, money hasn’t bought their loyalty.
But anyway, Jan has more or less just retired
ever since he left Facebook, and we don’t
really hear from him that much.
The only time his name comes up in the media
nowadays is whenever he makes another large
donation.
One of his largest donations was $556 million
to the Silicon Valley Community Foundation.
Jan says that Facebook barely changed his
life and that he still lives in the same house,
hangs out with the same friends, and more
or less does the same things.
He just has a lot more money in his bank account.
Brian, on the other hand, is more active than
ever before with the Signal Foundation.
One of the first things Brian did after leaving
Facebook was founding a competing messaging
platform called Signal.
Signal is a non-profit messaging platform
that focuses on collecting as little data
as possible.
Everything on the app is encrypted and so
far Brian has funded it with $100 million
of his own money.
Signal has actually become quite popular growing
an active user base of 40 million users as
of the start of 2021.
And given the virtuous goals of Signal and
how much funding they have, I can’t see
why the app won’t just become even more
popular within the coming years.
Eventually, they may even be able to give
Telegram and WhatsApp a run for their money
which is the goal.
So, Brian may end up being known for founding,
not one but two game-changing messaging platforms,
one for himself and one for the people.
Do you guys think Signal can replace WhatsApp?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you’re glad that Brian
is standing up to Facebook.
And of course, consider checking out our international
channels to watch our videos in other languages
and consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.